let's begin with basic combat training
this session will be recorded for
subsequent evaluation
this course is designed to reinforce
your fundamental combat abilities
and hone your reflexes the skills you
gain here will help you survive
even excel on the battlefield
i will train you to be effective with
firearms to use stealth tactics to
advantage and to hack into enemy
networks
because app
and militech can't encrypt for [ __ ]
but they clearly got drilling jar heads
in their blood
now station one you maggot
move move move hope you're ready
let's blast through a tactical target
practice program you know a little
warm-up
yeah i didn't think you'd find that too
tough what do you say we crank it up a
notch
not bad but it's more realistic if the
target's packing iron
quit standing around and take cover
you took a hit use a reanimator to patch
yourself up
head to the training area when you're
good to go
huh look
[Music]
[Music]
dreamwork v stand on the platform and
we'll move on
packing's the next item on the menu
might
[Music]
this training module will teach you how
to
work a little hack magic on the screen
to distract the guard
almost almost again from the top
work a little hack magic on the screen
to distract the guard
corvo trash style over substance
good now take him out quietly
all right all yours take him out
never smart to leave behind any trace of
your handiwork
especially the dead kind now pick up the
body and hide it somewhere
okay now try to take him down in one
slick move
you think you're ready to try hacking
some gonks in real time
have fun
so
now detonate
[Music]
see just needed to shut your brain down
and follow orders
in true militech fashion not too shabby
militech's algorithms put you on a
decent run
got additional modules if you want to
hone any other skills
before you finish up don't doubt now but
remember
the street's not going to give you any
hints or second chances
well we doing this
right so first let's shape up those
stealth skills
find cover quit nice nice
now move slowly towards the exit stay
out of sight
so
nova well done on to the next area
now the same thing only with the camera
[Music]
[Music]
the you're not a gunk-brained militech
recruit get moving
nice work today just stand on the
platform to exit the sim
the you're not a gunk-brained militech
recruit get moving
all right
time to get down and dirty in close
quarter combat
take him down but careful looks tough
okay that'll do now maybe we find
someone closer to your weight class
[Music]
oh
huh
[Music]
huh
[Music]
let's bump things up from easy to normal
this next pool
can block your attacks
[Music]
instead of dealing
[Music]
oh
now this fool loses his footing every
time he swings
use that get in there and land a counter
punch
[Music]
oh
i like that v want to see this fool
punching air next don't let him land
anything
you've done well in mastering the way of
the fool
i can teach you no more let's move on to
melee weapons grab a sword
good now show me what you've learned
good stuff looks like you're cruising
already
good luck vee
[Applause]
so not bad huh
now we can get down to biz
will kako give you any tips and tricks
for the job
i'm not your mother just do what i pay
you for
it's easy work yeah let's do this
elevator
you